all right buckle up tonight america's
enemies they're testing joe biden and as
per usual
yes you're very frail weak uh
cognitively struggling
commander-in-chief
yeah it doesn't seem like he's up to
this test while sippy cup joe is
enjoying a restful midweek getaway
at his beach house in delaware while
america's
food costs are now soaring why
because of another russian-based cyber
security attack
and meanwhile china is now threatening
get this an all-out nuclear war
and they are now allegedly expanding
their nuclear arsenal in preparation
for what they see as an intense showdown
with the united states of america
now this of course after the world is
finally recovering
from a pandemic that china definitely
caused
uh they did protect their own country
with a travel ban
couldn't travel out of wuhan province to
china couldn't travel from china
other parts of china to wu on province
but you could leave wuhan province and
go to the rest of the world
of course this deadly disease likely
originated as we're now discovering
from this lab the wuhan virology lab
nearly 600 000 americans are dead
because of
yes what china did and how they handled
it
millions more around the globe are dead
because of what china did here and
didn't do here
everyone's life was up ended for more
than a year thanks to
the communist chinese government hostile
actors a hostile regime
a hostile president president xi and not
only did they probably create the virus
and as we call gain of function and then
release it into the world
but then they tried to cover it up with
the help of the world health
organization
that you helped fund how nice the
malignant government of china must be
held accountable
sippy cup joe your president doesn't
seem too capable of doing anything
a good first step for the biden
administration would be
a little straightforward honesty about
the origins of covet 19 but
in order for that to happen well first
that guy dr anthony fauci the so beloved
the expert
follow the experts he now needs to be
fired immediately
now for months at the start of this
pandemic
we gave dr fauci the benefit of the
doubt we had him on the show radio and
tv
we listened to his advice but after
months of
serious miscalculations flip-flops
cruise ships masks lockdowns the origins
of covet-19
the models projections everything was
wrong
well rightly now our trust in doctor
flip flop pouchy is non-existent
who like the governor of new york is
apparently writing a book and making
money
we'll have more on that in a moment but
now thanks to the freedom of information
act or request
a trove of newly unearthed emails
they're painting a damning picture
of america's highest paid bureaucrat
that's fouchy
in one email january 31st 2020
it's only 10 days after the first known
case of coronavirus
in the u.s a team of america's top
scientists
studying covert 19 they warned fauci
directly
that quote some of the features of the
virus look engineered
this is 10 days after the first
identified case
in this country the exact day that
donald trump put that
xenophobic hysterical travel ban in
effect
one day later fauci and a top deputy at
the national institute of health
exchange frantic emails about what we
now know to be gain of function research
now for reference gain a function if you
don't know that research
often involves manipulating viruses for
the purpose of making them more
dangerous
more infectious and more lethal the
practice is
so risky that it was actually
temporarily halted
by our government from 2014 to 17
according to fauci's emails it appears
that the doctor was not only worried
that the virus was
the result of gain of function research
but also
that his nih that you the taxpayers
could have funded it
one email to fauci reads quote the paper
you sent me says
the experiments were performed before
the gain of function
pause but have since been reviewed and
approved by the nih and quote
someone at the nih will try to determine
if we have any
distant ties to this work abroad
yeah you gave them money but in the
following weeks fauchi threw cold water
on the theory
that covet originated in this wuhan
virology lab in other words it kind of
reads to me like bauchi possibly knew
damn well that the u.s could have helped
fund this really
and this seems like he wanted to cover
it up with the uh
the appearance of distance well in may
he told national geographic that he's
very very strongly leaning toward
a conclusion that the virus could not
have been
artificially or deliberately manipulated
wrong again
on multiple occasions fauci strongly
implied
that the virus originated in nature and
in an email to dr fauci in april
the nih director francis collins
referred to the
lab leak theory as a fox news fueled
conspiracy theory
apparently that's gone mainstream in the
same month a scientist named peter
dazak profusely thanked fauci in an
email
i want to say a personal thank you for
publicly standing up and stating
that the scientific evidence supports a
natural origin for covet 19
from bat to human spillover not a lab
release from the wuhan
institute of virology he continued from
my perspective your comments are brave
and coming from your trusted voice will
help dispel
the miss being spun around the virus's
origins
now dazzack has deep ties to china
and of course the world health
organization that you pay for
and his non-profit helps steer federal
nih grants to the wuhan institute of
neurology
so let me get this make this easy let me
break it down
millions of your tax dollars ended up at
the wuhan institute of virology between
2014 and 2019 when gain of function
research
on coronaviruses were taking place in
other words
the lab that probably created and leaked
this virus
2012 fauci even said oh yeah it's it's
dangerous but it's certainly worth the
risk to do
gain and function research but the real
question tonight is
what did dr fauci know when did dr fauci
know it
and was he engaged in some type of
scientific cover-up if not then why was
america's top infectious disease
expert so wrong for so many months
and of course as we mentioned just like
andrew cuomo
dr flip flop bauchi is now trying to
profit from the pandemic in a book
hilariously titled
expect the unexpected 10 lessons on
truth
service and the way forward thankfully
the book is only 80 pages long
so joe biden do you care to comment do
you still have all that great
faith and confidence and dr fauci i'll
do it if dr fauci says so you kept
telling us
because i hate to tell you joey i know
you're asleep right now
i know you've had your warm milky and
your little sippy cup presidential label
and everything
but we the american people do not have
faith
in flip flop bauchi who now must based
on what we've learned be
fired hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else